soirée de gala à poissy sur la même
pelouse au stade léo lagrange didier
deschamps christian karembeu laurent
blanc ou encore alain giresse
ils ont tous répondu présent à l'appel
du variétés club de france pour ce match
caritatif contre une équipe composée
d'amateurs ont fait ou qui ceux qui se
donnent maintenant qu'ils sont à la
retraite
donc en gros ça cool surtout que dis-je
f1 il était hier au stade de france donc
françois poule qui soit venu les deux
mille supporters présents ont même pu
apercevoir un petit nouveau au sein du
variétés florent malouda finaliste de la
coupe du monde 2006
je sais pas s'il veut mais c'est vrai
que corps que vous commencez avec le
variétés dire que c'est face à un cas
comme donc
donc oui guyane après bon il ya
tellement de joueurs que avec la fatigue
on va gérer mais ça va j'ai pas de
soucis ce niveau là mais l'attraction du
soir se nommer le joueur habitué au banc
de touche au psg à créditer le public
d'une grosse prestation pour son premier
match officiel de la saison
passement de jambes accélérations et
même passe décisive sur le premier but
de la rencontre
j'ai couru je me suis donné quand même
si je suis un peu fatigué mais c'est
normal quand on est sur le terrain pour
il faut donner ce qu'on a donc
donc voilà très content quelques minutes
après l'ouverture du score l'équipe
geodis adverse égalise le tableau
d'affichage n'évoluera plus score final
un but partout
ce cépage parce que sur l' affaire
n'aurait même a mérité on a beaucoup
d'opportunités on a fini plus fort que
les petits jeunes qui étaient sur la
polo à face donc c'est sympa
pas de vainqueur sur la pelouse mais une
grande victoire en dehors du terrain les
bénéfices de la rencontre ont permis de
récolter 15 mille euros en faveur des
associations urbain et plus de vie
soutenu par bernadette chirac présente
ce mercredi au stade de poissy le
variétés club de france devrait revenir
l'année prochaine dans les yvelines pour
assurer une nouvelle fois le show